monsieur Moscovici bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes passage à Montréal dans le cadre du
Forum économique international des
Amériques de Montréal la conférence de
Montréal vous êtes le premier président
de la Cour des comptes juste pour bien
comprendre ce que c'est un peu
l'équivalent du vérificateur de la
vérification générale du Québec
absolument que je verrai demain et je
vais aussi dire son homologue du Québec
nous sommes une institution qui contrôle
les comptes de l'État de la sécurité
sociale des collectivités locales avec
une spécialité française exception
ancienne créée par Napoléon qui figure
dans la Constitution dont le premier
président est toujours un homme
politique en tout cas fut par exemple à
mes processeurs grand ami du Québec
comme moi fut Philippe Seguin et donc
c'est une institution qui a comme on dit
chez nous pignon sur rue et qui donne
aussi des avis sur les projets de loi de
finances pour s'assurer de leur
conformité avec les règles européennes
j'ai été commissaire européen j'ai été
misé finance maintenant je fais en
quelque sorte le tiercé et je vous ai
reçu à l'émission reprise et vous avez
un poste différent à chaque fois que je
vous rencontre c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir
dans un contexte aussi où les taux
d'intérêt sont élevés la guerre en
Ukraine qui sévit et qui qui touche
l'Europe de différentes façons
dépression très grande sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur les finances publiques aussi
les coûts d'intérêt qui augmentent aussi
pour les États et c'est vrai en France
et c'est vrai au Canada est-ce que vous
êtes d'avis que les États doivent entrer
dans une phase de contrôle de rigueur de
restriction budgétaire de remarque la
première c'est comme ça quand on met les
chiffres bout à bout c'est l'air très
alarmant notamment quand on parle de
récession technique on dit ouh là là
l'Europe vraiment s'arrête c'est pas
tout à fait ça récession technique et le
mot technique ça veut dire deux
trimestres de suite de croissance
négative ça fait une croissance au total
de 0 un point
décroissance des 0 points c'est vraiment
très limité et je pense que le deuxième
partie de l'année sera vraiment bien
meilleure et que nous aurons une
croissance positive dans la zone euro en
France ça devrait être entre 0,6 et 1%,
ça devrait être relativement faible
quand même de toute façon c'est faible
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que en
vérité la au sens profond du terme nous
sommes plutôt en train de l’éviter même
l'Allemagne qui a ses problèmes de
dépendance à la gare de la Chine de
dépendance énergétique de dépenses égard
de la Russie de changement de modèle
productif même l'Allemagne devrait une
croissance légèrement positive en 2023
donc nous restons dans une situation
difficile comme le reste du monde mais
tout de même des partenaires solides
quant à l'austérité je n'ai jamais été
partis dans l'austérité parce que
l'austérité c'est ce qui a faibli l'État
c'est ce qu'il appauvri et dans le
moment où nous sommes on a besoin de
beaucoup d'investissements publics c'est
ce que je disais ce matin oui mais la
transition énergétique la transition
écologique la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique pour nous qui
sommes confrontés à la guerre et à la
menace russe la défense nationale la
santé et on a vu à quel point nous
étions vulnérables il faut s'armer face
à des pandémies qui peuvent revenir tout
ça alors justement nous avons besoin
d'investissement et nous ne pouvons pas
dans ce contexte là nous permettre
d'être endetté c'est pour ça que sans
plaider pour l'austérité je plaide pour
le désendettement il y a plusieurs
façons de se désendetter
on peut soit agir sur le paramètre
fiscal il se limite en Europe fiscal
c'est d'augmenter les taxes les impôts
absolument et ça nous avons comme des
limites parce que nous avons des taux de
prédominateurs très élevés en France
c'est quelques 44% du PIB ça fait quand
même beaucoup ou bien il faut dire sur
la dépense publique sur sa quantité 58 %
de dépenses publiques dans le PIB en
France ou bien sur sa qualité moi je
plaide beaucoup pour agir sur la qualité
la dépense publique il y a des dépenses
publiques qui sont utiles nécessaires
l'éducation l'innovation la recherche il
y en a qui sont même indispensables et
qui doivent être confortés tout ce que
je viens d'évoquer les investissements
pour demain les infrastructures il y a
aussi des dépenses qui sont mal
calibrées qui ne sont pas efficaces et
il faut je crois faire l'inventaire des
politiques publiques dans nos différents
pays notamment dans le mien en France
pour regarder ce qui marche ce qui
marche sur le conserve voir on le
développe ce qui ne marche pas on fait
des économies et donc le couper c'est
décompression ça c'est des compressions
dans certaines dépenses c'est une
révision des dépenses
la première de la Régie des rendes du
Québec et ensuite la ce qu'on appelle la
sécurité de la vieillesse et 65 c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose chez nous la
retraite est à 62 ans c'est à dire qu'on
ne peut pas toucher sa retraite avant
d'avoir 62 ans et donc c'est cet âge-là
qu'on augmentera à 64 ans je dis on ne
manquera parce que la loi quand on voit
les images là il y a des manifestations
calmes il y a eu beaucoup de
manifestations beaucoup plus violentes
il y a il y a une colère de toute façon
qui grandit dans la population et je
lisais en fin de semaine que la gauche
la gauche proteste et c'est l'extrême
droite qui carbure dans les sondages
est-ce que ça vaut la peine de faire
d'augmenter l'âge de retraite comme ça
alors si le résultat fait grandir une
opposante politique comme Marine Le Pen
avoue d'abord première chose je suis
président de la Cour des comptes du
point de vue financier il y avait un
besoin de faire une réforme pas
forcément celle-là mais une réforme pour
une raison simple c'est que nous sommes
des nations qui vieillissent et donc le
rapport entre les actifs et les inactifs
se dégradent il y a de moins en moins
actif il y a de plus en plus d'inactif
et dans ce contexte là le système de
retraite n'était pas chez nous
financièrement équilibré puisque nous
avons un système dit de répartition sur
cette technique ça veut dire que c'est
les cotisations que vous moi qui
travaillons au Verseau qui vont financer
nos retraites plus tard c'est pas un
système de capitalisation où chacun
épargne pour sa retraite c'est un
système totalement socialisé quasiment
totalement socialisé et il fallait
financièrement trouver des ressources
alors après je vais pas me prononcer sur
la réforme en question il pouvait y
avoir d'autres façons de faire on
pouvait agir non pas sur l'âge légal
mais sur la durée de cotisation vous
savez en France et je le dis pour nos
habits Canadiens qui ne s'imaginent pas
que nous sommes à préparer ceux on part
plutôt en retraite à 63 ans en moyenne
donc passer à 64 c'est juste la question
de l'âge légal ou pas qui était en cause
c'est vrai qu'il y a ça mais au fond on
est dans une période en France où il y a
beaucoup d'insatisfaction beaucoup de
mécontentements et Madame Le Pen
bénéficie de tout ça les élections sont
encore loin il faudra trouver le moment
venu des réponses peut-être différentes
le défi celui-là
les choix qui sont faits bien que
important sur le plan financier comme
vous le décrivez
ne sont pas sans conséquence sur le plan
politique également et sur le plan
démocratique est-ce qu'on a demandé trop
à la classe moyenne quand on parle
justement des retraites ou qu'on parle
des taxes des taxes carbone de la
transition énergétique est-ce qu'on met
pas trop de pression sur une bonne
partie de la classe moyenne en tout cas
chez vous comme chez nous en tout cas il
y a ce ressenti ce qui explique la
montée de l'extrême droite du Front
national en France qui explique ses
mécontentements qui sur les retraites
ont été plutôt pacifiques c'était un
mouvement social construit avec lequel
peut-être il aurait fallu avoir plus de
dialogue mais ça c'est une autre
question et ce qui explique ça c'est le
sentiment de déclassement c'est au fond
l'idée c'était mieux avant avant on
avait plus de protection avant l'État
était à nos côtés avant nous demandait
moins et ça je pense qu'il faut vraiment
je ne fais plus de politique moi mais y
répondre et il répond quand même
je fais je m'occupe de politique
publique voilà comme disent les
Anglo-Saxons
je suis toujours dans les polices je ne
suis plus dans la politique le combat
politique mais je m'occupe toujours de
politique publique et bien je pense que
il faut vraiment répondre à ça c'est à
dire qu'il faut offrir à nouveau un
avenir un avenir la question qui qui
entre nos sociétés c'est quel projet
pour demain quel futur quel futur pour
la jeunesse qu'elle présente pour nous
pour ceux qui travaillons pour la classe
moyenne et en effet ça doit être une
priorité parce que cette classe moyenne
le problème c'est qu'elle se vit
aujourd'hui comme justement n'étant plus
une classe moyenne comme étant une
classe en voie de paupérisation c'est à
cela qu'il faut répondre il faut
restaurer la confiance recréer les
conditions d'Amir grand mot vous me
direz oui mais c'est ça le projet
politique monsieur moscoviciste toujours
un plaisir de vous accueillir merci
merci à vous merci à vous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]